nos encontramos a unos kilómetros del
aeropuerto internacional de dinero y
aunque hemos intentado acceder a las
instalaciones por el momento no se da
permiso a la prensa porque siguen las
investigaciones lo que sabemos hasta
ahora según fuentes locales con las que
hemos consultado es que ha habido tres
bombardeos uno esta madrugada otro esta
mañana y el último hace apenas unas
horas y el aeropuerto ha quedado
totalmente destruido se ha atacado una
terminal la pista de aterrizaje y este
ha sido el peor de los ataques que ha
recibido esta ciudad de un millón de
habitantes desde que comenzó la invasión
rusa el ataque contra el aeropuerto
viene dos días después de que fuera
atacada otra infraestructura de
transporte en este caso la estación de
tren de cromatos donde murieron 50
personas la segunda fase de la invasión
rusa que se centra en el este y en el
sur del país está trayendo muchas
víctimas mortales civiles la mayoría y
también infraestructuras civiles